how you doing internet creatures i'm
dave rubin
and this is the reuben report direct
message for today april 22nd
2021 as always click that
subscribe button and tap that
notification bell so maybe you get our
videos
in your youtube news feed and before we
do anything i just want to quickly thank
a whole bunch of you because
i actually went through some comments
yesterday saw a lot of comments on our
locals community
and twitter and elsewhere a lot of
people said that yesterday was
the best show that we've done so far it
wasn't the funniest show we've done
i can assure you of that but i think it
was probably the most in-depth and sort
of
clear-minded and clean related to facts
and trying to stop this insane narrative
that's being forced down all our throats
and all that stuff so
i was glad to see that you guys are
digging it so today we are doing an ask
me anything uh we got over 100 questions
at reubenreport.locals.com i am going to
do one story up top obviously because i
want to talk about this
the reaction really to the mikaya bryant
story she's the girl that was shot after
attacking another girl with a knife and
now basically the entire woke left has
come out
four would-be knife murderers which if
you think
that that's as crazy as these people can
get just wait people you have no idea
how much crazier they can get so we're
gonna decipher some of that with video
and facts before we do any of that
though guys i want to talk to you about
1-800 flowers
you know a mother is someone who loves
you with all her heart i know my mom
does
so whether it's your birth mom's stepmom
or a strong maternal figure this
mother's day
celebrate all of the amazing women in
your life with a gorgeous bouquet
from 1 800 flowers dot com right now 1
800 flowers is
offering 24 multi-colored roses plus
a free vase for 34.99 this gorgeous
bouquet of two dozen roses and an
assortment of bright colors is
guaranteed to show all of the moms in
your life
just how much they're loved i can't wait
to send a 1-800 flowers bouquet to my
mom
i guess i just blew the surprise mom
you're getting flowers all the roses
from 1-800 flowers are picked up at
their peak
cared for every step of the way and
shipped fresh to ensure lasting beauty
pick up and early delivery date that
ensures your bouquet will arrive
in time to make mom's day special 24
multi-colored roses plus a free vase for
34.99 is an amazing offer but prices
will be going up so order yours today
don't put this off order today from the
official florist of mother's day
1-800 flowers dot com to order 24
multi-colored roses plus
a free vase for 34.99 go to 1-800
flowers dot com click the radio icon and
enter code ruben that's 1-800
flowers.com coderuben and now back to me
okay so we're going to get to plenty of
questions because you guys submitted a
whole bunch
at reubenreport.locals.com but i want to
just unpack
this mikaya bryant shooting in columbus
ohio quickly for you guys
uh because she was trying this is a 16
year old girl she was
trying in essence to kill another girl
with a knife
you shouldn't do that and she was shot
by a police officer so we're going to
show you first let's look at some video
this is from the white house
i don't think we need to show you all
the video again we're going to show you
some of it in just a moment
but first here's white house reaction
from that
real gem of a spokesperson jen pasaki
the killing of 16 year old michaela
bryant by the columbus police is tragic
she was a child we're thinking of her
friends and family in the communities
that are hurting and grieving her loss
we know that police violence just
proportionally impacts
black and latino people in communities
in that black women and girls like black
men and boys
experience higher rates of police
violence we also know that
there are particular vulnerabilities
that children in foster care care
like mikaya face and her death came as
you noted
just as america was hopeful of a step
forward after the traumatic and
exhausting trial of derek chovin
and the verdict that was reached so our
focus is
on um working to address systemic racism
and implicit implicit bias head-on and
of course to
passing laws and legislation that will
put much-needed reforms
into place at police departments around
the country oh
lordy lordy let me clean that up for you
so of course
what is this really about it's about
systemic racism that's what she says
she's going to focus
on now now there's no evidence this had
anything to do with racism that was an
officer trying to make sure that one
girl didn't kill another girl
in a civil society you're not allowed to
stab other people with knives so the
officer
did what they thought they had to do
again we can always talk about training
and whatever i heard a lot of people
saying
well she should have used a taser i mean
a taser doesn't always work it's a
little harder to aim
though she maybe still could have
stabbed her but we can have all of those
discussions but
they don't really want to have those
discussions because that they want to
have is discussions about systemic
racism
and how to burn the whole system down uh
there was also this line in there where
she says you know the disproportionately
that police violence disproportionately
affects
black and hispanic people and now
they're trying to tie hispanic people
into this the way they've been trying to
tie asian people into this
because they need you as groups and they
can't have you as free-thinking
individuals we all know that
uh yesterday we went through a whole
bunch of numbers on all of this stuff
in 2019 and this is according to the
washington post this is in some crazy
right-wing rag the washington post which
analyzed the data
2019 nine unarmed black people were shot
by cops
19 unarmed white people were shot by
cops that's more than double in case
you're
using math okay um and
she also is ignoring the fact that
behaviors have something to do with it
you know this is the weird thing with
equity they seem to want everything to
be equal so it's like okay if we shot 50
black people we got to shoot 50 white
people which by the way
that's sort of what they actually do
mean it's just like okay we can just get
more white people shot
then then we'll be okay in essence that
really is what they mean and i know this
will be clipped by media matters you
losers i'll get to you in just a sec
um so if we're going to deal with this
honestly which i know it's getting very
hard to deal with any of this stuff
honestly
then we have to talk about behavior that
behavior has something to do with some
of this stuff and we can talk about all
the reasons
that people act differently you could
try to read a thomas soul book and you
might realize some things about the
welfare state that did not help
behaviors and all of that kind of stuff
but we've got a whole bunch of other
stuff to get to so i want to talk to you
about lebron james quickly because he
posted a tweet so let's put his first
tweet up
so there's lebron's tweet now this has
since been deleted
and he is saying your next
accountability with a picture of the
officer that did the shooting now again
this officer shot a knife-wielding woman
who was attacking
another girl he then deleted that and he
tweeted this
i'm so damn tired of seeing black people
killed by police
i took the tweet down because it's being
used to create more hate
this isn't about one officer it's about
the entire system
and they always use our words to create
more racism
i am so desperate for more
accountability i i retweeted that and i
made a point of
giving lebron the actual numbers that i
just read to you from the washington
post he did not
retweet me unfortunately but this guy
loves narrative and i want to say
something about lebron you know you know
you guys know my feeling first of all i
have a basketball right behind me that
was used in a trailblazers
practice in 1991 i loved the
loved not love i loved the nba i loved
basketball i still
try to play even though i got a torn acl
on my knee i still watch old basketball
games
but i don't watch anymore i don't watch
new games anymore i haven't watched them
for a couple seasons i actually couldn't
even remember who won the nba
championship until someone reminded me
yesterday
it happened to be lebron in the lakers
um
nobody wants their stuff politicized
endlessly and at some level i actually
sympathize with lebron even though he's
got gajillion dollars he's afraid of
saying anything about china but he'll
endlessly tell you how racist
the united states is the whole euger
genocide thing in china
that that's not a real problem but but
you know america is racist you know he's
building like a 40 million dollar house
in la from what i understand right now
um but at some level i sympathize with
him because
he he just wanted to play basketball for
a living and that's a pretty freaking
lofty great goal
because i wish i played basketball for a
living i really do and i have no problem
with that but then he is asked to say
all these things and now he's in so deep
and the machine in essence won't let him
get out of it so imagine if lebron
actually in his real life started
reading about some of this stuff started
listening to the things that larry
elder's been saying for years that
thomas
sol has been writing about for decades
just looking at the actual numbers
looking at what the welfare state has
done all of the stuff that you guys now
know because you watch this right
imagine if he started waking up to it
and saying some of that stuff the mob
would destroy him so the machine
whatever that is whatever the machine is
the machine will not let this guy get up
for air in essence
so he just keeps repeating sort of these
dumb things
and then basically you know having to
delete tweets and then back them up you
know then the follow-up tweet is about
the racism in america
and all that and it's like yeah well
actually it's you guys that are ushering
in all this racism
but if you want to see how confusing all
of this is i always talk to you guys
about the reality war so that if you
watch
certain sets of news you don't get
sensible
honest reporting you get very skewed
reporting
so we're going to play a clip from nbc
news as they're talking about
uh the the shooting okay and i want you
to listen to what they're saying and
note where they cut
the video this is nbc news and remember
she was attacking
another girl with a knife in essence she
was about to kill her and then she did
get shot
this is how nbc reported it police body
cam video shows micaiah bryant's final
moments
when a columbus ohio police officer
responding to a call gets
out of his car and seconds later fatally
shoots the 16 year old girl
authorities say bryant was threatening
two other girls with a knife
it's a tragedy
there's there's no other way to say it
it's a 16 year old girl
so you see what they did there this one
isn't like totally
heavy-handed but the police was
responding to a call they didn't say
about the knife right then and there
right at the beginning they should have
said the police was responding to a call
that she was wielding a knife and
attacking somebody
uh they also stopped the video right
before you could actually see the knife
now i'll give credit where credit is due
so nbc you could see they just didn't
want to quite
say what the truth is and remember again
if she had stabbed that girl to death
100 with certainty um
that you would not know about this right
like it would not have made it to nbc
news that's the broader
point so nbc there they sort of the
police showed up as if that she's the
victim in this thing
okay which she obviously isn't um
and in essence they basically make the
villain the victim
okay that's what they're doing okay but
i'll give credit where it's due cbs
actually kind of did a decent job note
the difference
between the tone and the footage police
say they were responding to a 911 call
about someone who had a knife these
girls over here trying to fight us
when officer reardon arrived bryant
appears to be chasing
one girl before threatening another
slowed down police say the video shows
16 year old bryant
raising a knife officer reardon
repeatedly shouts get down
and then he fires which one of those
seems more honest which one of you shows
the perilous situation that the girl who
was being stabbed
was in that the cop was in right
they actually talk about the knife and
show you the full footage
so cbs i give credit where credit is due
you get some credit right there
okay you don't always do good stuff but
you did some decent stuff right there
and nbc clearly wanted to push a
narrative i think you guys all see that
all right let's just do one other thing
before we get to the q and a uh you know
i often note that these losers at media
matters they they
sit and they watch these shows i mean
media matters which is you know a sort
of media watchdog which it's a
non-profit that it's just funded
by millionaires that are on the left to
just take out
anyone who they don't like so they
they're always going after shapiro and
they're always going after prager and
glenn beck they've gone after me
so this loser it doesn't even matter
what his name is uh tweeted out a clip
from
me yesterday and i already said earlier
in the show i have no doubt that they're
going to selectively edit this stuff and
put it up
but dave rubin warns that anti-white
laws are coming
you know so they're actually quoting
something that i said but he's putting
it to his audience as if i'm doing
something racist right
like that's the whole point he wants
he's a media watchdog and he wants crazy
right wing dave rubin
to seem like he's racist um yes
fool and i actually followed up uh jason
rants over at ktth radio who's a really
good radio host i've done a show a
couple of times
he actually tweeted this after i i fully
explained to you guys why i think
anti-white laws are coming
because if you want equity and not
equality you're going to have to punish
certain people
as you raise other people we know this
is coming right
asian people at harvard i mean we've
been through this stuff a million times
the government is saying that they're
gonna hire based on equity
so that means you're gonna have to there
are more white people in the united
states this is just a fact
you're gonna have to not give white
people jobs so that you can give black
people jobs this is
this is the stuff that they're bringing
in not the stuff that i'm for but
anyways that's what i said on the show
yesterday he puts this tweet up
the implication being that i'm racist
obviously this loser and then
by total chance jason rantz happens to
post this that the washington
state department of health is letting
providers deny vaccines to whites
one provider denying white people
vaccines thinks that it's equitable
is that what you're thinking that it has
to be just be totally a free-for-all and
whoever comes in comes in
in essence because they're saying no we
want to give vaccines to black people
and marginalize communities first so yes
anti-white policies and laws
are coming and in essence they're also
here there's also something called
affirmative action which many people
including thomas soul and larry elder
and plenty of other people
have been arguing are racist for a long
time anyway hey jason how are you glad i
could keep you busy
okay uh let's move on to the q a stack
attack says what should be done to try
to combat the narrative
that people should fear being shot by
police
okay so we played or yesterday i read to
you
a whole bunch of statistics on this
stuff as a general rule
if you are not attacking somebody
violently and you do not resist arrest
you will not be um violently attacked by
a police officer you will not be shot or
attacked
or anything else uh the other case
that's happening right now this donte
jones one which
sorry dante wright which we showed you a
couple days ago
he was not only did he have a warrant
out for his rest but then they had him
in handcuffs he broke away drove away
he shouldn't have been shot it sounds
like the officer made a mistake all of
that stuff but the point is
if he would have gotten out of the car
and been handcuffed
then everything everything well
everything would have been fine it's all
it's all relative he wouldn't have been
thrilled with what was going to happen
to him
as he went into the system but
generally speaking if you get pulled
over i've actually only been pulled over
one time in my entire life
i was pulled over officer was uh
probably
about 50 years old he was training a
young officer who was probably about
you know 22 or so and he claimed that i
swerved and he wanted me to take a
breathalyzer and i'll tell you i was
nervous like you get nervous like
just fact i wasn't drunk i had one glass
of wine and i was fully open up
i was fully honest about that i was like
actually i'm just leaving a party
i had one glass of wine i was literally
uh basically i was making the left turn
right to get onto my street where i was
about to park on the street
but i was nervous and then he had me do
you know follow the light and i had to
stand on one foot and then i actually
did the breathalyzer and all that but
when he was asking me questions i was
definitely a little nervous probably a
little
stumbly fumbly and then when he realized
that nothing was wrong he just let me
get back in the car and that was it now
some people could be watching this
saying that's not what they would have
done to a black person you got away with
it
with your one glass of wine because
you're white but i don't think
generally speaking that these are bad
people and i don't think police go into
policing
to be racist i really don't i've met so
many police officers
especially in the last year or so and
they are not bad people that doesn't
mean that there aren't bad apples but
there's
also no such thing as a perfect system
so when jenn pasaki
said you know takes uh this clip of
the officer shooting a girl who was
about to stab somebody
and says this is proof that we must get
rid of systemic racism it's like well
then show me
how racism is in policing show me the
laws
where police are rewarded if they shoot
more black people or some other thing
and the reason is they can't but they
know that they can just keep saying
these things over
she can keep saying systemic racism over
and over no one's going to say anything
about it
and lebron can keep saying how racist
america is while he makes hundreds of
millions
of dollars to play basketball and it
just it just kind of is what it is
so the only way you can fight a false
narrative is with truth and
and it's tough because people will call
you racist for telling the truth but
that's really the best you can do
i would say you know there are short
five minute prageru videos
that you can show people i would hand
them some thomas soul books get them to
some larry elder clips
um have them watch the radical
right-wing
libertarian extremist dave rubin you
know there's ways there's ways
cynthia says how would you respond if
your child wanted to be a police officer
great question um i i don't think i
would want my child to be a police
officer and that is a really
horrible sad truth that i think society
is coming up against right now
we know that a ton of police officers in
all of these defund
cities that we covered yesterday where
now crime and murder is rampant
and in some cases it's tripling and
quadrupling we know that
officers are now retiring early they're
saying there's just
no point of me putting my life on the
line especially as i'm so close
to retirement when i'm not going to be
backed up by my department or my mayor
or my governor et cetera so we have a
huge problem on that front
and then for a young person for a young
person that says okay i want to
do my civic duty i want to i want to
help protect my neighborhood and all of
those things
now i have to wear a camera now if i do
this wrong this is going to happen
or if i do absolutely nothing wrong but
the race
situation fits the narrative that they
they want to get out well now i'm going
to be called racist
and i could potentially be jailed or a
zillion other things
or or in essence the mob and and the
sort of
the the feeling of society is just going
to go completely against me
it's like it's it's dangerous to be a
police officer in good situations
um but right now it's really dangerous
and this is a huge
problem so in many ways what's going to
happen is you're going to get
less and less qualified people to be
police officers
because a certain set of people are just
going to select out they're going to say
there's just no reason to do that
so now we're going to make policing
worse by constantly demonizing police
the people that you're going to get to
come in to be police
are going to be of lesser quality and
this is what the left does with
everything they never
their whole thing is equity we're going
to raise everybody but in essence they
basically destroy things to lower them
to the other standard
and once you understand that then things
start being a lot clearer
i can't see the name on this one there
we go dog mom with the recent
beyond outrageous comments from so many
on the far left woke
folks do you think the tide is beginning
to turn i do at some level but i'm you
know i'm hesitant to say it because
we're just at the beginning of this
fight but i do think
that in these two months or whatever it
is two and a half months of the biden
administration that every
patently ridiculous idiotic lefty woke
idea that could possibly be ushered in
is on its way in um i just read this
morning now that
the congress has put forth a bill for
the 51st state dc of the 51st state it
probably won't pass the senate
but the point that they are coming for
everything and expand
the courts as we know and the electoral
college and dc
as a state and critical race theory
background it's like
what is give me one thing that
joe biden of 47 years in government
stood for
that he stands for now joe biden stands
for nothing other than the momentum
of the woke left so i think more and
more good people are waking up we are we
are definitely
seeing signs of that actually barry
weiss
wrote a piece on her sub stack that was
what she does actually is she outsources
it so she lets other people write pieces
but there was a
uh educator in new york by the name of
paul rossi who's standing up against
some of this stuff i'm actually going to
do a mini interview with him
are we are we airing that tomorrow we're
going to put that up next week
and more and more people are standing up
and fighting against this but again i
think you just have to do what you have
to do in your own
in your own world in your own life if
you see your kids being indoctrinated
you got to figure out a way to get them
out of those schools
if you whatever it is in your life that
you can control
because they are coming for everybody uh
if you're following me on twitter and i
don't recommend anyone be on twitter
you know twitter moment is is becoming a
truly editorialized section so that
it's not just that they're manipulating
us with algorithms and shadow bands but
the stories they're choosing to
highlight and the way that they frame
them
it's like the whole machine is coming
against us but if you think it's bad
like just trust me guys your silence
only gives it room right it only gives
it oxygen so if you think it's bad you
got to do something now
because it ain't going to be easier i'll
just i'll just be quiet for a little
while and it'll pass me over no
it'll be far worse in three years you'll
be that much weaker
and you'll be that much more culpable
for all of the bad things that are going
to happen so
fight man uh jeffrey says do you think
tulsi gabbard might be able to help you
in finding some sane democrats
well first off if you didn't see it i'm
thrilled to announce that not only
does tulsi gabbard have a absolutely
thriving community on locals but she's
also an investor in locals
um so that's great and you probably saw
that we had a big
fundraising round a big seed round that
just closed this week and we've got some
great people
so that's very exciting but can she find
some sane democrats
um well i don't want to discuss anything
that i've discussed with her privately
but i will give you my perspective on
this which is that a sane democrat at
this point you're pretty much a moderate
republican
what what same democrat is there what
old school democrat is there
if you would have asked me 10 years ago
i would have told you that someone like
chuck schumer
and i think in his heart of hearts is
probably a somewhat sane democrat i
don't think he's
really a crazy leftist 10 years ago i
don't think joe biden was a crazy
leftist
even nancy pelosi 10 years ago or dianne
feinstein 10 years ago were not crazy
leftists
but the movement and the momentum and
the energy of the woke lunatics
has basically corrupted all of these
people you let it in the system and it
destroys the whole thing
so show me one democrat standing up
against it you know you want to
reincarnate
jfk you know all right then maybe we'd
have a sane democrat
but i don't think there's anything left
there and that is not to say the
republicans are so great
but they're considerably better when it
comes to lockdowns when it comes to any
of this woke stuff
why are texas and florida thriving why
are new york and california struggling
like
these things are somewhat connected we
know that right like we just know it
amy says i'm a high school biology
teacher and i'm concerned about being
mandated to take critical race theory
training
i'm trying to think ahead because i love
my job and i've been very concerned well
look
it's coming it's coming and again thank
you
libs thank you very nice liberals like
bill maher
you helped usher in joe biden because
he's not orange right
there was a guy guarding the door he was
the orange guy
and you guys all took him out because as
god said says he was an
aesthetic injury to you so you got rid
of him
and then what'd you get well you got all
of the awful stuff and who will come
cancel bill maher eventually it will be
the left it will not be the right who
are the only people that say nice things
about bill maher anymore it's people on
the right
who say i disagree with them but
occasionally you get something right but
but
you know the why you know my feelings on
this the sort of wider just decimation
of the liberal elite and you can figure
out who the names are it doesn't even
matter
it's much bigger than picking specific
people
but as for what you can do look it's
coming to your schools
it's coming to all of our institutions
it's coming to all of our governmental
institutions as well so what can you do
um don't say anything that you don't
believe
so even if they force you for your job
to do this now like i can't sit here and
tell you to quit your job right like you
have to think
through your life you know when i was on
tour with jordan peterson when we would
do the q and a's a lot of things were
about
i'm at a job i don't like what do i do
and one of the things he would often say
and i'm not even saying you don't like
your job by the way i'm guessing that
you do like your job
as a high school biology teacher and
you're trying to figure out how to keep
your job and
and keep your dignity and all that right
you i think you specifically said you
love your job so
like how do we how do we deal with that
well one of the things that jordan would
say is okay if you're not happy about
your job
or that you're not happy about something
happening at your job you can't just
quit tomorrow like you have to think
about your life
holistically like okay do i have a
spouse do i have kids what are my bills
situation do i have another job prospect
it's my resume in order
like if you think about all of those
things and let's say you really want to
keep your job because that's what it
sounds like it's like
maybe you have to go to these trainings
and
i would say probably you should at least
register a complaint with someone now
most likely
they're going to ignore it and actually
most likely you'll probably get called a
racist and then it's very possible
they'll try to come for your job too
and that's why this all sucks because
you just want to live your life
and and have dignity and self-respect
and fight for truth
but the acquiescence as i just said is
is the much more dangerous path
the path to do nothing is more dangerous
so i would say at the very least and
again you have to
you have to factor in all the things in
your life to figure out
how to deal with this but at the very
least if you go to these trainings and
let's say you don't
register a complaint you don't say
anything to anyone well i would hope
that at the very least if they're asking
you to talk about this in biology class
biology you know these stem things
biology
and math and science and physics these
things that are beyond
racism although racism is coming
perceived racism is coming for all of
them
i would hope that at the very least you
would just not teach it just not even
talk about it but that's not a full
answer
it's not a full answer and this is this
is a great challenge for everybody so i
hope that gave a little bit of insight
uh storm says if the usa loses its way
it is no longer a freedom-loving place
where else is well china i would assume
china you know these
wokesters seem to love china these days
everyone on the left loves china
i guess we go to russia sure you know
putin's you know jailing his political
opposition or maybe venezuela would be
nice
or cuba i guess would be spectacular i
mean the joke is
and i say this all the time but the joke
of course of all of this is when you
listen to aoc and these ridiculous
workstars
they always tell you and bernie always
scandinavia he always talks about sweden
and denmark they're so great i've been
to sweden i've been to denmark i've been
to finland
okay these are great countries i enjoy
being in them they're tiny
tiny teeny tiny countries with mostly
homogeneous
white scary white people societies and
it's only in the last 20 years
that they've had an influx of migrants
often brown migrants
and now they are having huge problems
the united states on the other hand a
country of 350 million people that
everyone on earth has tried to come to
to make a better life by and large
they've always done it
we've integrated better than any society
we in our 250 years
have integrated more black brown asian
gay straight
christian jew muslim blah blah blah
people than
any other country all the european
countries that have existed forever
right the european countries that
existed for hundreds and hundreds of
years were a pretty new country
we've done it better than everybody and
they're still telling us all the awful
things about ourselves
so i where would you go i don't know
bora bora is nice but they've only got
like i don't know how many of those huts
above the water
you know that that ain't cheap so i
don't know
gals gulch that's that's where you gotta
go um
okay jared says as another gay
conservative how do you think we can
reach out to others in the gay community
that the answer for our equality is less
governmental regulation
and not more um i hear this a lot from
gay people because gay people are waking
up you know gay people are sort of the
other
right i've discussed this with douglas
murray who's a who's a gay conservative
even that phrase is sort of silly he's a
person he's a human
he happens to be conservative in his
political beliefs and he's gay in his
private life okay zippity-dippity
um but we've discussed it before and
what he has said to me is that perhaps
because of being the other
in that regard related to sexuality that
gay people their skin is a little bit
thinner let's say when it comes to
all of the things wrong with society one
of the interesting things for me is i
was never really that into
gay culture i you know i talked about
this the other day i went to some gay
pride parades
married a gay dude so you know i i know
about this stuff a little bit
um but i was never that like i did i
never liked drag shows i actually always
hated drag shows because they all seemed
like hack comedians
so i never liked any of that i don't
really care for rupaul's drag race or
any of that kind of stuff but if you
didn't know this story real quick 2016
election
i used to live in west hollywood it's
like the gayest place on earth and i go
to my polling station
and i'm trying to figure out like i
literally did not know if i was gonna
vote for hillary or trump i just did not
know what i was gonna do i ended up
voting for gary johnson
whatever um but i'm online at the west
hollywood
polling place like the gayest place on
earth and i'm standing behind rupaul
who was a man in that moment wasn't
dressed up in drag and it was
a little sidebar there what gay people
have to realize and i would say every
minority has to realize this
is that it's not the state telling you
that we're for equity that is going to
make you truly equal it's
it's equality under the law which we
have gay people can get married there's
nothing
stopping you from doing anything if
you're gay do whatever you want and is
it possible that some people won't like
you because you're gay
it is and guess what is it possible now
that some people won't like you
because you're straight it is there's a
fairly radical lgbtqi
lmnop movement happening and they don't
really like straight people
society can't solve all of your problems
but but what gay people should realize
is
when when they were coming for gay
people like back in the stonewall days
and when
every gay bar you know it's like i'm not
that old i'm 44 years old but i do
remember in my
say mid-20s or early 20s going to gay
bars and they were all in these like
dirty dingy places with blacked out
windows and all of that stuff because it
was this it was this subversive thing
and it wasn't really safe and were you
going to be outed and we
gay people were not equal at the time
well now
it is we we are equal actually in
chicago the gay
area in chicago used to be called boys
town now they they don't they're not
allowed to say that anymore i'm not
kidding
they call they call it something else
can you google this whatever they call
boys town now
um because it was it was too incl
exclusive because it sounded like it was
just for gay men
or something but i remember the first
time i went to chicago
after living in new york city and i
couldn't believe that in chicago
their gay bars had windows and they were
sort of out on the street and you could
see other human beings
that's within my lifetime so the gay
movement has
has achieved what it's supposed to
achieve but as chris rock says the cops
need a certain amount of crime and glad
and the hrc and these ridiculous people
they they raise
money media matters all of these people
raise
money off of
you feeling like you're oppressed but
when you were when when gay people were
hiding and going to these places with
blacked out windows and all this stuff
it was because the government was going
to come in right it was the government
that was coming in to arrest people and
charging them with all of these things
and all of that stuff
so what you would want is people to be
free and not have to deal with
government intervention that would be
the truest thing and by the way i see a
lot of
gay people waking up to this and uh we
do fact
we do facts in the middle of the show i
get facts flying at the screen
boys town in chicago is changing its
nickname after an online petition
claimed it wasn't inclusive of women
gender non-binary individuals and people
of color
it will now be advertised as north
alstead with the slogan chicago's
proudest
neighborhood you see we've stopped
homophobia people we don't call it boys
town it's now called
north falstad which sounds like a place
in game of thrones
okay anya says how not to give
up seeing the chauvin verdict federal
push for crt and all the madness and
corporate media i feel that i feel very
deflated
and i want to give up you know what i
hear you
um i think you've heard it in my voice
in the last week i've been more
frustrated than usual a little more
despondent than usual at some level
but the key thing for any of us if you
love freedom if you love america if you
love
forget america forget freedom if you
love life if you want to live and you
want to be free and you want to love who
you want to love and find a job that
gives you purpose
and and do something that makes you
happy on this
little mortal coil that's spinning
around the sun then
understand that not all the answers are
going to come from politics and
politicians don't have the answers
pundits don't have all the answers i
don't have all the answers you don't
have all the answers
but there's ways to figure it out like
like i could just tell you in
in my own life like when i wake up in
the morning i try to do a little cardio
in the morning i try not to stare at my
phone
all morning we try to eat really good
food right like
that's what we try to do we listen to
music we walk the dog like
all the little things that life is about
there's this other set of people there
they're purposely making everything
political because
because they know that will keep you
angry it will keep you focused on
on other people instead of yourself and
i think
more and more people are going to
realize the answers have nothing to do
with this and we just must build
things and i mean not to sound like a
commercial but that literally is why i
started locals how
i can't solve all the big tech problems
i don't think i can get these people to
move on anything
um and maybe it's not even because
they're all evil but the machinery is
just so big you can't move you know what
i mean like
it's like the titanic hitting the
iceberg like they needed to know earlier
and that's sort of what big tech feels
like but you know if you have a slim
trim boat and you know you got a couple
people instead of thousands of people
and
you don't need all those guys downstairs
throwing all that stuff into the
all the coal into the fires and all that
stuff you can move a little bit quicker
so that's what i believe the future will
be it'll be smaller not bigger
and we just we just got to get there and
have a little hope and as jordan
peterson would say
that star in the distance who was
wishing upon that star that guy knew
what he was doing
uh guys part two of my interview with
chef andrew gruel
is up at uh is up on youtube actually
and of course the full episode is up
absolutely ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
uh well i don't want to say too much but
it's very possible i'm meeting
dozens and dozens if not hundreds of
people in
socal sometime today perhaps in orange
county
there would be only one way you would
find out that might be at
reubenreport.locals.com but i don't want
to really hint
too much and maybe some of the media
matters people will come that would be
very
i'll buy you a drink uh guys tomorrow
we're doing an environmental panel with
bjorn lomberg benji backer and alex
epstein we're going to talk
about sort of a let's say a right or
conservative or libertarian position on
the environment are there ways to fix
some of the problems without just hoping
that the government can do it and giving
aoc and her green new deal more power
over our lives
i think there's a way all right people i
hope you're feeling a little more
enlightened
a little more decent a little more ready
to get out there and make a world that
you want to make
i'm going to do a couple podcasts today
and then as i said perhaps i'm seeing
real people tonight don't toe on me
have a good day everybody and i'll see
you tomorrow